well it's a great pleasure to introduce
Kim I met Peter Kim for the first time
in 1978 when he was an undergraduate at
Cornell a couple of things were really
notable and have stayed with me the
first is his booming laugh that I'm sure
many of you heard have heard during the
last couple of days it penetrates walls
travels down hallways and is really
quite remarkable the second thing that
stood out was his focus and ambition on
the kinds of problems he wanted to work
on at that time he told me that he was
interested in working on the biophysics
of protein folding I kind of raised my
eyebrows and said boy that's a really
hard problem and he said yeah but it's
really important he went off to Stanford
in the MD ph.d program and worked with
buz Baldwin where he actually succeeded
in defining the fundamental principles
that underlie the folding of every
protein in inside cells and did a
remarkable job as a graduate student he
left Stanford to become one of the first
crew of Whitehead fellows that the
then-new Whitehead Institute in Boston
stayed on the faculty there and had
similarly a spectacular success in
continuing his work he defined the
structure and principles of the leucine
zipper fundamental protein-protein
interaction problem that underlies how
proteins such as Fossen jun make
heterodimers he also defined fundamental
mechanisms by which viruses enter cells
with the spring-loaded mechanism in
influenza virus as well as HIV this work
was very well recognized in the field he
received the National Academy of
Sciences molecular biology award the
Hans Neurath prize of the protein
Society and he was elected to the
Institute of Medicine and the National
Academy of Sciences nonetheless in 2001
he was recruited by IDI Skolnick to
Merck and in 2003 was named the
president of Merck research labs a
position that he continues to hold today
I didn't have to ask him why he took
that job but it was seemed pretty simple
it was very hard and it was very
important all of the great work that
we've heard that we do in academia and
we've heard about these last two days
will go for naught unless these basic
science principles are translated into
new well therapeutics and we're very
fortunate to have someone of Peters
talent and passion to have been willing
to take on this problem Merck runs a
research portfolio of about 8 billion
dollars in R&D budget per year and so
you can imagine the challenge that it is
to take such an enormous operation and
try to get it to productively focus on
the right problems to answer really
important problems in human health
during his time there a number of
fundamental new mechanisms have been
exploited - new pharmacology and
therapeutics for human diseases
including the human papillomavirus
vaccine and sittig Lipton for the
treatment of type 2 diabetes and just
this week the very favorable review by
the FDA of the protease inhibitor for
hepatitis C virus infection so today
he's going to talk to us about what is
really one of the hard and important
problems in human health developing
preventive therapy for HIV Peter
thank you very much Rick and thank you
Bob and Yale School of Medicine for
inviting me to this really wonderful
event which is been a real pleasure to
participate in as Rick said I would like
to talk to you today about a very
difficult problem that we face and the
problem statement is illustrated on this
slide it's been estimated the most
recent estimate from the United Nations
and the CDs the World Health
Organization is that there are currently
over 33 million people on earth who are
living with HIV now what that means is
that approximately one out of every 200
people on the planet is currently
infected with this virus and I believe
that this remains as the largest public
health issue that science needs to
address as we move forward it's not been
an easy issue to address
and indeed shortly after the virus was
isolated Margaret heckler who was then
the HHS secretary put out a statement
saying that we hope to see a vaccine
ready for testing in people in about two
years she said that in 1984 and then she
went on to say yet another terrible
disease is about to yield to patients
persistence and outright genius
unfortunately the fact of the matter is
that patience persistence have not led
to a vaccine for this infectious agent
in spite of efforts on the parts of many
who you may consider it to be outright
geniuses but they still haven't solved
vaccines are a very important part of
what we do at Marc we are interested
obviously in and we try to create drugs
to help people but we also have a long
history in vaccines going back on this
slide to the measles vaccine in 1963 and
as you can see over the years
murk has had a long history and a rich
tradition of producing vaccines which
are extraordinarily cost effective way
of preventing disease most recently as
Rick mentioned you know one of the real
successes has been the vaccine for the
human papilloma virus marketed as
Gardasil which prevents over 70% of
cervical cancers you know every year
over 500,000 women get struck with
cervical cancer and over half of them
died from it and this vaccine which is a
virus like particle have proven
incredibly efficacious against
preventing the infection of human
papilloma virus and a consequent
acquisition of cervical cancer the
history of Merck and vaccines really
centers for the most part around a very
legendary person who I had the great
fortune of getting to know before he
died and that's Maurice Hillerman
Maurice Hilleman was someone who a
microbiologist who worked at Merck for
over for nearly 30 years he's actually
been credited with saving more lives
than any other scientists in the 20th
century indeed of the 14 currently
routinely recommended vaccines Hillerman
was responsible for eight out of those
14 and it's been estimated that the
vaccines that he created saved literally
eight million lives every year so it's
with that sort of passion and history
that Merck has had a long-standing
interest since the virus was discovered
of trying to come up with a vaccine
against HIV indeed HIV research has been
part of Merck since as I say the vaccine
was discovered the vaccine was excuse me
the virus was discovered in vaccine
research started early reverse
transcriptase inhibitor research
protease inhibitor research and
integrase inhibitor research led to the
discovery of Crixivan one of the first
protease inhibitors stockman or a
fabrice which is a reverse transcriptase
inhibitor and recently i centrists which
is an integration hibbott er for the
treatment of HIV but coming up with a
vaccine to prevent HIV infection has
proven to be very difficult you know
many of the vaccines that we have today
rely on attenuated or killed viruses or
organisms and indeed live attenuated
vaccines work extremely well for polio
measles mumps rubella and varicella but
so far and the field tried very hard
particularly in the early days it's not
been possible to come up with a safe
window for HIV between sufficient
attenuation to prevent disease and
sufficient safety - excuse me -
sufficient attenuation to allow for a
vaccine but without having safety issues
in that window killed viruses work well
for hepatitis A and polio but so far in
HIV in preclinical primate studies have
not proven effective so the field has
really started out initially to try and
come up with an antibody mediated
response against HIV there was a great
deal of work that went on by many many
people around the world to try and do
this and for the most part this has been
uniformly unsuccessful and then that has
also led to efforts in cell mediated
response just to very very quickly
review many many people's work over many
years much of the work to try and come
up with an antibody based vaccine has
been focused around the envelope protein
of HIV called gp120 and what is found is
that the mutation rate of the virus is
just astronomical the rate at which this
virus replicates is very very high and
although it's been possible to isolate
broadly neutralising monoclonal
antibodies rarely from infected patients
and you know i need to emphasize that
this is a very rare event to be able to
do that it's not been possible to
demonstrate a broadly neutralizing
neutralization activity by vaccination
and I'll just say that that's really
been it's not for lack of trying
there's been a lot of people that have
tried very hard Merck was among those
that tried and also failed and that led
then to efforts to try and do something
which had never really been done before
and that's to create a vaccine based on
a cell mediated immune response and
that's the first story that I'd like to
tell you today this is a it's actually
not a new story it's an old story but I
think it's an important story to tell
because it gives us a status of where it
is that we stand in this effort
the idea behind creating a cell mediated
immune response vaccine is to prime the
immune system such that circulating
cytotoxic t-lymphocytes will go around
in the body and those CTLs will
recognize an infective cell and then
kill that infected cell so the idea is
not to prevent the initial infection but
rather to kill cells that are infected
using the stimulation of the cell
mediated immune response and there
basically are four steps that one wants
to go through here first one needs to
identify what vaccine antigens you want
to express in order to elicit the
vaccine response then you need to select
the best way of getting that cellular
immunity and then obviously tested in
preclinical models which for us or
non-human primates or monkeys and then
finally to test them in the most
promising candidates in a clinical study
and so for the first step what was done
was to look at infected HIV subjects and
to look with different peptide pools
corresponding to different proteins in
HIV and what's shown here is that
there's a very good response across
different clades against the gag Neph
and Paul proteins and so I'll just tell
you that the final vaccine that was
tested here included gag Paul and Neff
as the expression second thing that was
done and I'm now summarizing just an
enormous amount of work was to go
through in a very systematic way through
different vaccine technologies and to
test their ability to actually elicit a
cytotoxic T lymphocyte response and here
I list the different technologies that
were tested preclinically in and the
best ones that showed efficacy in
non-human primates were then eventually
tested in people as shown with the ones
in blue here I'll show this result here
and pause a little bit because this
result this shows that using the best
technology which turned out to be an
adenovirus a replication defective
adenovirus called adenovirus v this
shows in a direct assay that what these
workers were able to do was to elicit a
cytotoxic T lymphocyte response in
monkeys using the MRK or merck ad v
vaccine expressing in this case gag and
what it shows here each of these four
groups groups of four points are from
one monkey and what's done is to isolate
PBMCs or peripheral blood mononuclear
cells from monkeys that have been
vaccinated with this vaccine and then
those peripheral blood mononuclear sites
are put on top of autologous be self B
cells which have been primed with a gag
peptide pool so that the target cells
now are expressed I have on their
surface gag peptides and what you see is
when you add now the effector cells to
the target cells they kill about 70
percent in this one monkey of those
cells that these are different effector
to target ratios and this is the control
here and so the top panel shows you that
in six different monkeys you're getting
good killing of these target cells this
is at a virus particle concentration of
10 to the 11th particles but the bottom
left shows here is that even at ten to
the seventh virus particles or four
orders of magnitude less we're able to
obtain an effective CTL response in
monkeys now one of the things that we
worried about with using an adenovirus
carrier replica
defective adenovirus is that some of
these monkeys and some people will have
been infected by naturally wild-type
adenovirus as part of a respiratory
infection and so as a result this shows
the results with monkeys that don't have
antibodies against adenovirus five
whereas over here we have monkeys that
were showing adenovirus antibodies and
what you can see is that the response is
diminished but still in two out of these
three monkeys here there's a solid
cytotoxic T lymphocyte response so the
conclusion then is that this vaccine is
able to elicit a robust cytotoxic T
lymphocyte response against the HIV
expressing cell b-cells so then the
question was well what does it do in
terms of infection so in a typical HIV
infection what happens is in the period
of the first few weeks after infection
the virus load rises tremendously and it
hits a peak viral load within a period
of weeks and then the viral load
decreases as the immune system kicks in
and depending different people have
different what are called set points but
basically you reach an equilibrium
between the virus replicating and the
immune system attacking the virus and
that set point can last typically four
years and different people have
different set points and it's been shown
very convincingly that the prognosis of
patient depends on the level of the set
point the higher the set point divorce
the prognosis ultimately after a long
period of time the immune system wins
and the viral load takes over and the
patient then the cheese franc aids so
the experiment that was then done was to
take monkeys and to immunize them with
the merck & v vaccine expressing gag pol
and f the control group used just empty
adenovirus v as a control and high dose
IV
Challenge so Shiva simian HIV a high
dose IV infection was given a dose that
will guarantee infection and here are
the results on the left hand side as you
can see the monkeys that were vaccinated
these are rhesus monkeys the rhesus
monkeys that were vaccinated actually
still got infected with this high dose
of HIV administered intravenously but
the peak viral load was diminished by
approximately one log and the set point
was reduced by approximately three logs
in some cases coming down to the levels
of detection and that level of the viral
set point as you can see persisted for
up to two years on the right-hand side
whoops we got a on the right hand side
is the gag specific cd8 cells so these
are the CTL cells and what you can see
is that in the control you can't really
see but there's just a little blip
during infection but in the vaccinated
monkeys what you can see is a very rapid
and domestic response in the cytotoxic
t-lymphocytes
following infection with the thank you
following an infection with the HIV so
taken together now
these results show that we were able
actually to produce a immune response
which was able to respond to the
infection and to control the level of
the Varinia substantially in these
monkeys in humans we showed that we were
able to also elicit a durable t-cell
response and what I haven't shown you is
a really enormous amount of work showing
that these responses here which are
based on what's called an le spot assay
correlate with the CTL response that
I've showed you earlier and what this
shows is that in humans which have a low
adenovirus five titer or a high
adenovirus five titer we were able to
obtain in between fifty and seventy
percent of the subjects a good and
durable response
against these these peptides with a good
t-cell response as shown here during the
course of the development of vaccine
from time to time an individual that we
were studying would become infected
during the course of the study and this
slide shows the results of one such
individual so this individual is
immunized and at week eight what's shown
here are this is overlapping gag peptide
pools so this is a gag protein shown
here in 9-mer peptide pools and what you
see is that there are cd8 responses gag
specific cd8 response is shown in blue
that are hitting certain peptides in the
gag protein following infection this
person got infected and following that
infection what you see is that those in
many cases the same response was in fact
amplified following the infection
showing that the the vaccine primed the
immune system and the infection actually
led to expansion of a substantial number
of the epitopes that were seen that were
that were primed so we're able to get a
good response with cd8 positive CTL
cells in in humans and as I just showed
you that response is actually one that
is a monistic when a person does get
infected so that then led us then to the
proof-of-concept study the phase two
study this was called the step study it
started in 2004 it enrolled
approximately 3,000 seronegative adults
who are at high risk of acquiring HIV
there was a collaboration between the
HIV vaccine trial Network the NIH and
Merck and what we were interested in was
seeing whether or not this vaccine as
compared to placebo would in the
patients and in the subjects that had a
low adenovirus titer whether it would
reduce infection or if it didn't reduce
infection whether it reduce the viral
load end point and so specifically we
focused the primary hypothesis on those
subjects who did not have privacy prior
exposure to adenovirus vaj and what we
saw in the vaccine is that the vaccine
was efficacious and that if many of the
subjects showed a response in le spot or
CTL response against the gag call and
Neph proteins and the majority of
subjects showed a response against more
than two of these antigens and indeed
what we found was that the median number
of epitopes that was that was recognized
by subjects was approximately five in
this study so what about infection well
in in blue are shown the results for
infection now this is an acquisition of
infection in the vaccinated subjects and
in black open circles of those in the
placebo subjects so first thing you can
see is overall the vaccine did not
protect against infection the primary
hypothesis was in these subjects here
who had not had prior exposure to
adenovirus five and what you see here in
the primary hypothesis is quite clearly
the vaccine did not provide protection
against infection as compared to the
control the two are practically
overlapping for those subjects that had
prior exposure to adenovirus five
there's actually numerically a more
patients the more subjects that got
infected with HIV that had the vaccine
than on placebo a result that led to
that's led to much speculation which I
won't go into right now for this part of
the talk so obviously this was a
disappointment and the vaccine although
with vaccine had no effect on infection
when we ran the trial now while few of
us really saw this as the ultimate
vaccine I think many of us or some of us
myself certainly included thought that
the vaccine might even if it didn't
prevent
might lower the viral setpoint it might
actually have an effect of boosting the
immune system's ability to lower the set
point and so the results of the set
point viral load are shown here overall
there's no effect on the level of the
set point and importantly in the primary
hypothesis where patients these subjects
have not been exposed to any virus
before you can see that clearly there's
no effect on the viral set point really
a very clear negative result with
respect not only to infection but also
with regard to what happens after
infection in terms of the viral load so
futility was declared in 2007 three
years after we started this trial and
the trial was stopped and we've been
making the samples from these trials
available to investigators through a
collaborative network that Bruce Walker
oversees for further analyses but
obviously the results really I think
clearly demonstrate that the vaccine did
not have an efficacious it was not
efficacious in these subjects and I
think it really sets a solid framework
for what doesn't work in terms of a cell
mediated vaccine for HIV because a
vaccine that was tested did show
efficacy in rhesus monkeys and the
vaccine that was tested was shown in
humans in the majority of acts knees to
result in significant t-cell responses
exactly the way we wanted nonetheless
the vaccine was not effective as I've
just shown you and so I think it would
be reasonable to expect that any next
step in terms of testing for cell
mediated immunity can be benchmarked
against the cytotoxic T lymphocyte
responses that we've seen here in this
vaccine leading up to this trial overall
it's obviously pretty discouraging
because you know one gets to a point
where one has a hypothesis and one
verified hypothesis in your best
preclinical species
in this case rhesus monkeys and
establishing you this you've achieved
the t-cell response that you want in
humans and yet you've seen no effect
whatsoever on infection and I think what
this calls for really is for really a
step change in terms of the vaccine
technologies that we need if we're going
to use a cytotoxic T lymphocyte approach
to prevention of an HIV vaccine and
certainly work towards understanding how
to even get an even greater and more
robust CTL response either through
vaccine
excuse me through adjuvant or through
manipulation immune system in other ways
is something that's going to be very
important I think these results also
though point to the importance for the
field to continue to work on different
ways to develop an HIV vaccine based on
the humoral or antibody mediated immune
system response and one such approach
that is being pursued at Merck actually
is based on work that started many years
ago when I was at the Whitehead
Institute in MIT and ultimately led to a
collaboration with Merck and now has
been taken over in large part by John
Shriver at Merck and I'd like to tell
you where we stand on that end many
years ago in actually 1993 chav a car
when she was a graduate student in my
lab discovered what we call the
spring-loaded mechanism by which the flu
virus influenza in fact infect its cells
and basically what the spring-loaded
model indicated was that the flu virus
influenza underwent a major
conformational change which allowed it
to become a viral a membrane protein two
membranes the target membrane and the
cell membrane at the same time and then
subsequent conformational changes led to
fusion the overall structural hypothesis
that we put forward was in fact
confirmed in crystallographic studies by
the late Don Wiley and his group and
Meccan mechanistically using
mutagenesis Judy White's group at
University of Virginia was able to show
that she could change residues in this
spring and get the virus to no longer in
fact although it could still bind to
cells we speculated then and later went
on to show that the HIV gp120 gp41
envelope protein would also use a
similar spring-loaded mechanism and in
that spring-loaded mechanism the gp120
would bind to the cd4 and the
co-receptor undergo a conformational
change and that would allow gp41 to
undergo the spring-loaded conformational
change in which a three stranded coiled
coil would form at the end terminal end
of the protein and the so called fusion
peptides which are these hydrophobic
peptides about 20 amino acids in length
would insert into the cell membrane such
that this intermediate now would be one
in which the protein was inserted into
both the cell membrane and anchored in
the viral membrane and then in a
subsequent reaction the end terminal end
of these HeLa C's and the C terminal
region these protein would snap together
to form this trimer of hairpin or the
six helix structure here which would
bring the two membranes together leading
to fusion and allowing the virus nucleic
acid to enter the cell one of the very
explicit predictions of this model which
postulated this pre hairpin intermediate
would be that we should be able to
inhibit this fusion reaction by
developing specific inhibitors that
bound to this pre hairpin intermediate
indeed we were able to design and
identify inhibitors that did bind to the
pre hairpin intermediate and that did
prevent HIV infection so for example we
could take peptides from this C peptide
region over here and make them
synthetically and they would infect they
would bind to the n-terminal region and
prevent infection in a dominant negative
sort of way similarly the crystal
structure that we solved of this protein
complex showed a nice pocket in the part
of this in Terminal three stranded
coiled-coil
and we were able to use phase displayed
to identify peptide inhibitors which
bound to that pocket and we showed this
is the x-ray crystal structure of that
complex and we showed that these
peptides which bound to that pocket did
indeed inhibit HIV infection so that
showed that you could bind to the
n-terminal region of this intermediate
and inhibit infection we then asked
whether or not you could do the converse
could you bind to the c-peptide region
of this intermediate and inhibit fusion
and one idea that Michael Kate
Michael rude Michael Kay came up with
was to take the six helix structure and
remove one of the Gila C's so that you
have essentially a receptor for one of
the c-- peptides over here so they made
a structure called five helix which
contained five out of the six Gila C's
and sure enough it bound very tightly
with nano molar affinity and inhibited
HIV infection by binding to the C
peptide region of this and similarly
using the three stranded coiled coil at
the end peptide region we could show
that those were inhibitors of this
intermediate as well and so these
structural studies showed that they were
binding where we thought that they
should bind and the HIV infection
studies showed that they were inhibitors
of HIV infection indeed one such C
peptide which had been identified by
Carl wild and his colleagues down at
Duke before we actually came up with
this spring-loaded hypothesis one of
these C peptides turned out to be a good
inhibitor and went all the way through
clinical trials and is currently sold by
Roche as fusee on it's an HIV inhibitor
it's an injectable therapeutic and so a
peptide corresponding to this part of
the course find one of these C peptides
is a bonafide therapeutic in humans
which is to say that this pre hairpin
intermediate is one that has been
validated therapeutically in humans the
question that we asked many years ago
and we've been struggling trying to
answer since then is could the pre
hairpin intermediate serve
a potential vaccine candidate could you
actually come up with a way to get
antibodies against the structure and get
antibodies to bind into this structure
in the same way that we got these
peptides and small molecules to bind and
thereby prevent HIV infection now
because this pre here Penn intermediate
is transient by definition it's a
transient in structure we can't use it
to immunize people and similarly you
wouldn't expect to get in antibodies
against it since it's a transient
intermediate but we had developed
through our studies of these inhibitors
we had developed mimetics of this
intermediate and so we could use these
stable mimetics to ask whether or not if
we made a mimetic of this end peptide
region like shown here could we actually
get something which would elicit
antibodies and lead to inhibition and I
can tell you now without showing you all
the negative data that for many years we
tried and were unsuccessful in getting
antibody responses that inhibited HIV
using this methodology and we were about
to throw in the towel I'm coming back to
Mike Brown's persistent we were about to
throw in a towel when we decided well we
would just give it one try with a where
we actually did selection using a phage
display monoclonal antibody library and
so instead of immunized animals with
these constructs what we did was to take
these constructs and to see if we could
pan and pull out from a phage display
antibody library an antibody which bound
to these mimetics and which inhibited
HIV and of course
sure enough such the antibody was
identified and that I that an antibody
which we call d5 was able to inhibit HIV
infection across a bunch of different
HIV constructs different HIV species
with not great activity but nonetheless
with bonafide activity and importantly
it was a broadly neutralized
activity and when the crystal structure
of the antibody bound to the
intermediate was solved it showed that
indeed the antibody bound right where we
wanted it to and it showed that there
was sufficient room between the cell
membrane and the viral membrane for an
antibody to reach which was a concern
that we had about the approach so armed
with the this then provided proof of
concept that an antibody could do what
we wanted it to do even if we could
readily elicit them in animals I'll just
say that we've gone on and studied a
bunch of different constructs which
contained the end peptide region of gp41
these include different ways of hooking
this trimers together covalently they
include ways of shielding the scaffold
part of the protein using polyethylene
glycol and they include different
lengths of these constructs and the
other thing that we've done we did was
to actually design a mutant envelope
protein which fused slower which stood
in the pre hairpin intermediate for a
longer period of time and that contains
a single amino acid substitution at
position 570 availing to alanine and
without going into details inhibitors
which work by binding for the pre
hairpin intermediate were much better
against this mutant that inhibitors
which bind to other parts of the
envelope protein and what that did was
to give us a higher sensitivity to look
for the needle in the haystack
indeed as shown on the left-hand side
here now using in different colors of
different in the different antigen
constructs that I showed you earlier on
the left hand side using the more
sensitive virus we're able to in guinea
pigs
each symbol is the separate animal we're
able for the first time to see now
activity that is protecting neutralizing
against HIV infection when we use the
wild type virus that activity is
significantly decreased but nonetheless
some of the constructs were seen some
activity and ultimately that led to us
focusing in on two of these antigens and
what I show here is data from David Mont
fury at Duke who's the resident expert
in screening these things against a
bunch of different pseudo viruses from
different clinical isolates and the
numbers here are 1 over dilution of
unfractionated guinea pigs zero so you
know what we're seeing is that you can
take guinea pig serum without
purification unfractionated and now in
some cases at delusions of greater than
1 in 50 get neutralization of these
clinical isolates of HIV this is the
first time that we've been able to
demonstrate from unfractionated serum
that we can actually detect an anti HIV
activity following immunization
unfortunately the results in rabbits
were not was good these are for guinea
pigs and rather than focusing on rabbits
is what we're doing is we're moving
forward into monkeys and now we need to
see how we do there I can tell you that
based on where we are here my gut
feeling is that we still have a long way
to go but we're we're stet where we're
headed is to first assess these
neurological responses in monkeys and to
see whether or not we can reproduce
getting serum which does show activity
again neutralizing activity but then I
think we really need to and it's not
just we Merck I think it's we as a
community really need to think about
other strategies to also enhance the
immune focus on this part of the protein
and I just say that given what has been
tested today in HIV in trying to get
illicit HIV antibodies it's my personal
feeling and obviously I'm biased here
but it's my personal feeling that this
is the most promising approach even if
it is a long way away it's the most
promising approach that we current
we have and I would state the following
reasons first of all the drugs you see
on has provided clinical proof of
concept that this is a good therapeutic
target the preclinical experiments as
well as now while the preclinical
experiments have demonstrated bus excuse
me the monoclonal antibody a crystal
structure have demonstrated that indeed
the antibody can get in there and this
is a viable mechanism for doing this and
the preclinical experiments now for the
first time have given us a response in
polyclonal serum that is detectable that
we can move forward with I should also
say that these parts of the proteins
that we're dealing with are highly
highly conserved and one of the reasons
why they're highly conserved is I think
because they have to actually be able to
fold up into two very different
confirmations in the pre hair in the
native structure they're folded
essentially as an unfolded loop and then
when they go into the pre hairpin
intermediate they fold up into alpha
helix C's so there are two very
different structures and so amino acid
substitutions need to be accommodated in
both of those structures in order to in
order to survive and so as it probably
as a result of that when you look across
different strains there's a high level
of conservation in these regions of the
proteins so the prospect of getting a
broadly neutralising activity as we have
seen preclinically is one that if i want
to be an optimist like charles i can be
optimistic about so you know the work
that i've talked about actually spans
well gosh goes back 20 years 25 years
and i've only focused on part of this
john Shriver really as I said at the
beginning has headed up much of this
work Mike Robertson was responsible for
the clinic the clinical monitor for the
step study the work that I talked about
he originated the whitehead MIT really
I've put in particular focus on chav a
car David chan and Debbie Eckert for
their work here the HV TN and the NIH as
I said were collaborators on the trial
and much of the work that I haven't told
you about
mark large part often negative results
were also extensive collaboration with
the academic community and the biotech
community as we try in our efforts here
to do something about this really great
medical problem that we face as a
scientific community so thank you very
much